welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar automation meets
cell separation primary cells for drug
discovery assays presented by
lithography global product manager cell
separation Melton new biotech
my name is Xavier Gutierrez and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Milton E biotech
for more information about our sponsor
please visit www.michigan.gov/mstep
emply click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and type your questions into the
drop-down box our speaker will respond
to your questions via email following
the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're experiencing
a problem this presentation is
educational and this offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits now
without further ado please join me in
welcoming literati I would now turn the
presentation over to her
Thank You salsa from my sides and thank
you for joining our presentation today
today we'll be talking about automation
needs sales operation primary cells for
drug discovery assays the agenda for
today's presentation is first of all
Milton e biotech the pioneer in sales of
red cell research and south era P will
also look at density gradient
centrifugation and south operations
directly from Luca fact and buffy coat
will then take a quick step into
automated cell isolation and finish up
with the applications in drug discovery
assays
so let's not Milford biotech was
actually founded in 1989 by Stephan
Milton II the basis of the max cell
isolation is the column technology that
he developed as part of his diploma
thesis and patented in 1990 already in
the beginning stages
Stephan had a pioneering spirit and he
saw the potential for max technology to
become a revolution either in the field
of gene therapy the clinic max cd34
reagent system is a method for selecting
hematopoietic stem cells for from donor
a phoresis while defeating t-cells that
can cause graft-versus-host disease the
development of the system went over
forever went on for over 20 years and it
included setting up a GMP manufacturing
site in Tetro in Germany and finally the
cd34 isolation using the clean Emacs
together with the clean max cd34 reagent
received FDA approval in 2014 currently
the treatment of patients with acute
myeloid leukemia is in first complete
remission
what started out as one man's diploma
thesis has since grown into a global
company of 2,500 employees worldwide and
over 20,000 scientific publications
fighting max technology annually
more than 2,500 patients receive sell
products manufactured by Milton with
mouth milk and biotech technologies the
wood is max technology about
max technology requires only three easy
steps firstly you have the magnetic
labeling where an antibody conjugated to
a tiny paramagnetic microbeads binds to
a receptor or protein on the cell
surface there are different strategies
for doing this and we'll get to that in
a little bit later the second step is
the magnetic separation where the cells
are passed through a column that's
positioned within a magnet the cells
labeled with the microbeads are retained
in the column while everything else is
washed through in a gentle way through
the column the flow through is called
the negative fraction and it contains
the cells without the marker for the
antibody or antibodies that were used
for the isolation
in the illusions that the column is
removed from the magnet enabling the
magnetic field label cells to be washed
out this can be done either manually
with the plunger to push the cells out
or automated using a vacuum to pull the
cells out or increasing or by increasing
the flow speed of the buffer in the
system all of these three methods are
gentle for the cells and separate the
cells into the negative and positive
fractions with exceptional purity and
high viability
therefore max technology is based on
three components first the max microbead
secondly the max column and the Max sex
there are magnetic separators there are
several versions of each of these
available depending on your starting
material the cell type of interest and
whether you're using a manual or
automated system this the column is the
heart of the match technology let's take
a quick look at why we use it and why is
superior compared to column pre method
the magnetic separators in a column
based and column three systems have
comparable magnetic force the difference
between the systems is the column that's
filled with little is spheres each iron
steer passes the magnetic force onto the
next over very small distance which
amplifies the magnetic force by ten
thousandfold and ensures that the
magnetic field is constant throughout
the column
the minimal labeling of cells with tiny
nano beads tough surfaces to retain
target cells in the column
the iron spheres have a self and
decoding and the cells can run freely
throughout the column through the column
and be washed thoroughly to remove all
cell debris and contaminants all this
contributes to the fact that max columns
allow for cell separation with minimal
effects on cells
therefore max columns are the best best
choice for sales operation with minimal
effect on sales or translator for
translational applications
this translational approach from bench
top to bedside is reflected in all of
our products we provide the same
products in research grade as well as
GMP and clinical quality to ensure
smooth transition into the clinic we
provide the entire workflow of products
for sale based work from tissue
dissociation and homogenization to cell
isolation and culture including
activation and expansion of cells as
well as cell analysis by a flow
cytometry in the end
before we go into the specifics of
primary cell isolation let's consider
the use of primary cells and cell lines
in drug discovery primary cells are
sourced by culturing cells derived
directly from human or animal tissue
cell lines on the other hand are
generated by immortalizing primary cells
with vectors and cultivating them over
many passages the cell cultures is that
the result of this type of this
methodology they disavow me from with
regards to resemblance to the top to the
tissue of origin and the characteristics
and relevance to predict individual
biology so what are the differences well
primary cells generally are limited in
supply because you have to have fresh
fresh material cell lines on the under
hat other hand are virtually unlimited
because they can be cultured for almost
indefinitely primary cells have a have
low presence for literally for
liberation in culture and they're for a
limited time span lifespan and cell
lines on the other hands are on the
other hand are easy to culture and
primary cells have high donor variation
of course because all of us are
different or primary or primary tissues
are different the cell lines on the hat
other hand don't have donor variation
the cell lines that are derived from
primary tissues has low mutation rates
whereas high whereas cell lines would
have high mutation rates and may
continue to change in culture primary
cells are representative of the
biological phenotype and complexity of
the biological system that they
originate from on the other hand cell
lines have low relevance in vivo and
they're focused they need to be focused
for research on a specific target and
finally primary cells are pretty much
pre characterized and ready to use
and of course the cell lines need to be
immortalized first and you need to have
identical of course there are a lot of
concerns of a misidentified and cost
contaminated cell lines for example in a
study of over 500 Leukemia and Lymphoma
cell lines 15 percent of the cell lines
were misidentified and booked us also
some argue that tumour cells obtained
directly from patients are the best way
to study cancer these these sources can
be you can ask me for the for the
sources for these concerns later on so
primary cells are more relevant for the
complexity of the biological systems or
systems that we're working with they can
be a little bit more difficult to obtain
but how do we actually isolate primary
cells
and primary cells are provide more
relevant data which is of course it with
just mentioned
so let's take a look at the use of
primary cells in drug discovery and the
steps involved from your starting
material to sample preparation followed
by magnetic cell isolation and the
downstream applications
you
most primary cells come from blood
products which are maybe human there's a
lot of flexibility in this area
depending on the number of cells you
need from whole blood from and bone
marrow with limited cell numbers to
buffy coat and luca paths which are
larger in size and can't contain a lot
of white blood cells tissue on the other
hand can be of urine or human origin and
can be either healthy tissue such as
Queen or lymph node or tumor tissue
patient is patient-derived xenograft in
meister often also used in research
whichever starting material you start
with in the past they've all required
sample preparation for you to be able to
be able to work with the cells so let's
take a look at the sample preparation
for these materials
you
the sample preparation step is mostly
density greatest
this sample preparation step is mostly
density gradient centrifugation to get
PBMCs or in the case of tissue
dissociation of the tissues for example
with the gentle max dissociation to get
a single cell suspension after this you
can proceed with the cell separation
we've seen these steps already
previously the magnetic labeling
magnetic separation and the illusion of
label cells to get the population of
interest and depending on your project
you have different options to select
from would you rather go for an easy and
fast positive isolation or do you need
your epitopes free for a second sort so
do you prefer an untouched isolation
where you can label everything else with
the population of interest or do you
have many samples and would rather
separate them in parallel compared to
one after the other
would you rather freeze your aliquot
freeze a loquats of your PBMCs or
isolate north all directly all of these
factors are important in deciding which
strategy is right for you
you
once you have your population of
interests you can move on to the
downstream application whether it's an
additional separation set of sub
populations for example t-rex will flow
cytometry searches immuno sanitizing we
can recommend the kids that will make
these steps easier will you maybe
culture the cells in in vitro assays or
run genomics or proteomics applications
whether you are interested in maximum
recovery searches for cell culture
assays or high purity for reliable
genomics or proteomic studies we can
help you with the strategy to get that
will discuss options of immunophenotype
things and functional assays later I'd
like to take a look at the PB NC steps
before we move on to the example step
and a summary of what we've done so far
in traditional approaches we go from
blood products to PBMCs to target cell
in the end from
as a summary of what we've learned so
far in traditional approaches we go from
blood product to PBMCs to target cells
in two steps for this we have the max
micro beads for positive isolation
and isolation kids for untouched
isolation where we label everything but
the target cell in this process you have
to go from task sample to target cell
why a cycle
I'm sure I don't know I'm sure I don't
have to tell you what cycle looks like
not going into detail there are many
steps you have to centrifuge you have to
count cells it takes a lot of time and
it's prone to human error and use the
variation then this is why we're
introducing the hassle free alternative
to five all the straight from microbeads
the straight from product line allows
you to isolate cells directly from blood
products without sentence density
gradients without cell counting and it
only a few simple steps there's little
hands-on no user variation and is the
fastest available protocol for target
cells from buffy coat and looper puck
the protocol is really simple you
transfer the Buffy coat
Luke effect or lr SC into a suitable
vessel and fill up 280 milliliters if
the volume is less than that this
example is for a buffy coat but it's
similar if you're working with LR SDS or
Luca packs then you add the microbeads
and incubate in the fridge after which
you can separate the cells using the max
multi-max self separator we'll get into
the instrument in a little bit but with
this protocol you can go from an entire
buffy coat to target cells in as little
as 25 minutes or from half a loop go
back to the target cells in 40 minutes
without sensitive certification no lysis
and no counting
now we can fill in the other option to
cycle the straight from microbeads for
direct isolation of target cell from
blood products we've just brought out
the new products for buffy coat
luca packs and LRC
so to summarize so far we've now learned
about primaries are what we need to
consider when planning a project by
sedating cells the steps to isolate them
from from tissue or blood products as
well as the shortcuts that we can take
everything we've talked about aims at
generating assay results that are
biologically relevant reproducible and
as efficient as possible
saving hands on time and unnecessary
steps and repeat work in the lab the
reagents we work with are only one half
of the solution truly efficient and
reproducible results of results and
protocols require automation so I'd like
to take a few moments to discuss
automated solutions before going on to
discuss drug discovery assets
so why do we need automation in the
first place as we've already said
automation reduces hands-on time and
frees you to work on other more
important tasks that cannot be automated
it minimizes variation between different
users in the lab or even good and bad
days of an individual scientist and of
course if minimizes cost means human
errors with standard protocols and
minimum user variation you can be sure
that the effect you're seeing are due to
the assay with standard protocols and
minimum user variation you can be sure
that the affect your thing are due to
the assay rather than artifact in short
automation reduces redundant experiments
and allows you to focus your time where
it matters and very shortly I'd like to
introduce the Milton e biotech automated
solution for magnetic cell separation
we'll start with the automatics Pro
separator the easy-to-use benchtop
instruments for every lab with deformity
automated sequential separation from one
to six sample
the automatics is it provides easy
access to automation without high
investment costs or lots of training you
can mix many different starting
materials and samples within one one and
you can press the Run button and the
instrument will label and separate the
valves for you
the columns are reusable so the
maintenance is easy and there are preset
programs for high recovery and high
purity depending on your downstream
application
you
if you have more than six samples or
large samples such as puffy coats you
might want to consider parallel cell
isolation the multi-max family is
perfect for this you have 24 magnets
that allow you to process 1 to 24
samples in one run will fit your sample
between multiple columns this is
achieved by using the LS l GE or Hobart
column or the multi 24 column block for
easy handling of 24 samples or an entire
Luca pack the multi-max L 24 is a
semi-automated instrument and it's a
good fit for many labs that value easy
handling but don't mind the additional
pipetting however if you want full
automation and maximum throughput
you will love the multi nuts X which
integrates the multi maps into a liquid
handler it was only just launched one
and a half years ago and this instrument
is for the demanding high throughput
cell processing lab samples our labels
and also all science samples are labels
and isolated automatically and you can
go from an entire buffy coder to target
cells in 30 minutes or from an entire
Luca pack in 60 minutes all programs are
tailored to match your needs so we don't
leave the lab until you're satisfied
with the protocol and the results
procs as you can see the heart of the
multi-max X is the multi-max cell 24
with the Aleutian chamber to leave the
label cells and the deck layout around
it that ensures fast and reliable
processing the storage hotels store
people place
with butter waste or the negative
fraction and the sample can be processed
from 15 or 50 milliliter retro racks
that keep the cells called during
incubation the buffer trusts provide
buffer for the isolation and the 1 and 5
milliliter disposable tips are used to
transform reagents and samples
throughout the deck
so in summary we have the three
automated solutions the automatic Pro is
great for small samples and low
throughput with full automation for
example when you're processing PBMC
aliquot Mouse samples or patient-derived
xenograft because the automatic can
process all blood without cycle is also
great for patient methods for patient
samples or for small donor samples from
the other hand the multi-max family are
the high throughput variants for fast
parallel processing for example of small
human or mouse sample but also for large
blood products such as puffy coats and
Luka packs
we've now learned that the sets of
primary cell isolation and how to ensure
match maximum efficiency and
reproducibility by selecting the best
reagents and instruments to match your
workflow at this point I'd like to take
the chance to go through some
application data from assays frequently
run in drug discovery and we'll start
with Senate if ik and high content
screening
another big screening can be used for
biologic and small molecule development
the example here is small molecules
where we looked at the binding of CCR 2
on the surface of monocytes using high
content screening in the development of
an anti-inflammatory drug a CCR 2
inhibitor CC r2 is expressed on
monocytes and it's the binding site for
MC p1 a female kind that attracts and
activates monocytes in the top row you
can see the blue monocytes on the left
the red mCP one in the middle and the
overlay shows that the cells and NCP one
are Co localized in the middle of Rome
unlabeled mCP one was added in excess to
block all modified binding sites and as
you can see no stains and CP 1 can be
detected the same is seen when TCR to
inhibitor is added so there is no NCP 1
signal and since because there are no
binding sites free when you then look at
the cells of interest you can get much
more information on a single cell level
for example the cytoplasm shape size and
area of the new blue
the next X the next example that we have
is the use of stealth operation in the
development of Mars models in this
example of the humanization of the mouth
you would over irradiate the mouth and
transplant human cd34 positive
hemorrhage products hematopoietic stem
cells isolated for example on the item X
Pro infusing these cells into the area
did it into the irradiated mouth allows
you to grow a humanized Mouse immune
system in some in the mouse of course
you can then monitor the success of the
humanization by isolating the human
immune cells of populations after the
infusion
infusion
in the later stages of the drug
development process you'll be needing
lots of fine results for the mechanism
of action profiling of your drug in the
example of an ml RSA you will isolate
monocytes from one donor and t-cells
from another to co-culture the matured
disease with the T cells
adding for example a checkpoint
inhibitor molecule allows you to track
the t-cell activation for example by
interferon gamma production as you can
see here
t-cells and controls by themselves show
no t-cell activation as you can see in
the black black white and gray bars
however when you add the PD one antibody
or PDL one antibody you can show
interferon gamma production in all three
donor pairs as a sign of t-cell
activation in the orange and blue color
another method of moai profiling is the
t-rex oppression essay here you isolate
the T cells and stimulate them and then
add get the t-rex during the co culture
you can track the inhibition of t-cell
activation by the t-rex
and adding the drug compound you can
detect the compounds that inhibit the
tier 8 inhibitory effect as you can see
in this graph the same method can also
be used for for example the MDS C
suppression assay which is based on the
same principles
you
I also wanted to quickly show you an
example of a DCT si for britain
predictive immunogenicity here you
isolate the monocytes and the t-cell add
your peptide mix
and check which peptide court which
peptides cause see DTS cd4 T cell
proliferation these compounds have the
potential to be immuno genic
immuno genic and of course you need the
respondent and of course you need the
response here to be as low as possible
and here on the right you can see that
the data correlates well with the
clinical data that was gathered
afterwards
the last example that I'd like to show
is from the field of immunophenotype
Inge here first you would have sin genic
for example sin genic German but of
course you can use patient-derived
xenograft as one you can dissociate the
tumor for example using the gentle max
dissociate er isolate at the single cell
to get the tumor cells and the tumor in
syrup infiltrating sauce and then run
immunity no typing if you look at the
data without pre Richmond you can see
that you can see you can find hardly any
cells because you because you're
analyzing the bulk tumor you're
analyzing everything that was in the
tumor and if you only have a couple of
cells in a gate it's hardly clique card
hardly scientifically relevant data
however if you first isolate materials
the tumor infiltrating lymphocytes out
of the bulk tumor tissue and then go on
to analyze those you have much more a
much higher frequency of cells that
you're starting with and you will get
that relevant data that you're looking
for and you can be sure that the effects
that you're actually seeing are the
relevant ones that you're looking for
so in summary we've learned today that
primary cells are evolved valuable model
for biologically relevant assay results
you should select the best to ensure
maximum reproducibility starting with
single cell suspensions or going
straight from to reduce those at the
handling steps
and tailored automated cell isolation
solutions makes our work more efficient
and reduce handling errors in drug
discovery assays
I hope I was able to give you some into
insight into the worlds of sails
abrasion and their strengths and
pitfalls to make your choice a little
bit easier to select the mast if you
have any questions I'd love to get back
to you and thank you so much for taking
the time to join us today
Thank You Lora Rati for the informative
presentation I would also like to thank
Milton E biotech for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that this
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May of 2019 as a final
reminder our speaker will follow up with
any questions you submitted via email
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye